[Music]
I'm gay I'm sorry
come on don't hit me look at how happy
she is [ __ ] christ this is what it's
like to be a parent we're becoming
fathers we will have our first baby
these are babies that they use for like
educational purposes so it's gonna
function like a baby but it's just it
looks a little creepy we're gay but
we're not dating
we're not dating no I don't know if
we're gonna be friends after this I
think I'm gonna be a great dad like
dream job is dad do you want kids yeah
I'm the oldest of three siblings we're
definitely gonna be a better parents
than Jen and Nikki we're gonna have this
baby for a weekend do plants you have
smoke weed and cry we figured out a good
schedule for both of us and then on
Sunday we're just gonna have fun with
our baby I just have to marry somebody
that doesn't have ADHD and it'll bounce
out I don't have HD HD is he a wise not
yet don't look at me Bart okay this is
Bart he came right out of my vagine join
Addison Duggan win it was our one
condition for the weekend is that
neither of us is allowed to call the
other one daddy it's you I oh [ __ ]
back to work cool okay Sabino we'll see
how this goes by day one and we are
gonna go get dinner and my loving baby
mamas sexy baby Jamison and I are taking
our baby Addyson over here to dinner
it's her first time in
as soon as again the drive-through would
have to interact with people just start
screaming screaming okay well in it in
and out they like come to your car
window to talk to you so it's like a
person it's not like a box can I please
get one number two coke I think we must
have done something bad all we were
doing was going through a drive-thru
which is the easier option of getting
fast food and it was still really hard
night one of fatherhood absent and acted
up a little bit and it's just really
hard to listen to a baby cry in the
backseat and you can't do anything she
just doesn't stop we decided that we
were gonna go to sleep over the next
night so Jenna left I was all I had the
baby I started getting really into it
without even noticing
I started caressing her and then I
thought oh my gosh wait this baby isn't
a real baby Friday night was great super
chill
Saturday was one like all hell broke
loose
my glass is broken half and I went into
Target and of course she wants her
diaper change so I'm just like okay
clear all the clothes off to the table
everybody's walking around and they're
like staring at me hardcore and judging
me I was just like you know what I have
a baby
take care and so I changed her diaper
right there I tell Nicky okay I'm gonna
be at your apartment by like one or two
thirty no you said like new Jenna so she
had a haircut at 10:30 and then she'd
come by after to get the baby she just
texted me and told me her hair Co is
actually at 1:30 so she's not gonna be
here until 3:00 so while you're gone my
sister comes to visit and we try to go
get food the second I step outside the
car or she starts screaming babies have
sensitive necks like real babies so if
you put their necks in weird positions
they get very upset because you're miss
handling them okay there's only so much
I can do I'm one person it's time for a
little quality time with me and well
Meza Addison now I'm gonna try and cook
a meal for myself I don't know I feel
kind of guilty just leaving her behind
can't wait to be reunited with my
daughter screaming he's yours now hey he
was so calm as soon as I got to Nikki's
house that baby just like did not cry
trying to get ready to go to a birthday
party and she says that she's now hungry
I don't know how new parents can be
anywhere on time because time really
stops when your baby needs to eat or
drink or do anything we are going to
Olive Garden a family restaurant because
what a family we're next to it
with actual children
he's real nothing was happening he was
sleeping but I was so anxious just
sitting there waiting for something to
happen there was like an element of
pride like I am responsible enough to
have a child and to have a somewhere
where he can sit also all the miners had
leave after 10 p.m. but since Addison's
a robot she was saying Nicki's gonna go
to sleep in her room I'm asleep next
bill and I get out here and if he cries
I will start crying and that was surely
wake Nicki up around 2 a.m. she started
crying she didn't wanted to be fed so
did that drink from her ball for like 15
minutes which doesn't make sense that
length of time having a child the early
years is pretty much a guarantee you
will not get a good night's sleep much
the time we are on the way to going on a
morning stroll with Addison I'm sure
I'll get emotional on the stroll
time is it then it's kind of it before
have you looked from this couch you know
this has been great like there's been so
much fun I've loved it just the idea of
not having Addison anymore it kind of
scares me anyways and then we met up
with Jamison and Kevin for Brendan
I think if anything I just learned that
like doing it for like two days at a
very easy level it was frustrating so
it's like the fact that you can do it
for the rest of your life is impressive
so thank you moms and dads sorry mom I
thought it was like pretty good and
responsible but at the same time it's
like it's a handful because you don't
realize it until you're actually in it
that you're doing it that you're like oh
my gosh is what parents do it's like a
second job having like a kid so the
babies have like a computer inside that
monitors like your response time it
monitors how much you take care of them
it can tell if they've been mishandled
Addison knows we love her I totally
think that we did better than Jenna and
Nikki yeah I think they're gonna do a
better score just because it seemed like
they actually fell in love with their
kid yeah they like cared but yet C+ what
that's a solid B we would be a parent
what that's not possible
no way there's literally no way that
that's possible 47 out of 100 what did
Jenna Nikki get shut up that's not
possible hope baby we own 86 and they
got it honestly thought we'd come out at
the bottom on this one I refuse I refuse
to believe this I'm gonna leave now good
job buddy we didn't we did
and we stayed friends this is why I
can't measure parents and yeah you can't
measure it I know I'm gonna make the
parent
[Music]